le network est loin
[Musique]
c'est le cri d'un bébé qui appelle sa
maman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau
cette reprise étaient bonnes
bienvenue à tous sur le tournage de pet
des montagnes 6
merci de nous avoir rejoint ici dans
notre bulle merci à tous de vous équiper
comme il se doit les contacts physiques
sont évidemment défendu donc pour
compenser je recommande de pratiquer
sans retenue le regard de braise si vous
vous demander en quoi ça consiste je
vous montre
trop génial c'est comme si mon post airs
préférés venait de prendre tu vas vite
apprendre à lire les comètes ya
seulement deux films en production en ce
moment si on se plante la société va
toucher le fond je ne suis pas magicien
je sais que vous n'êtes pas magicien si
vous étiez un magicien vous pourriez me
pons de mon film pur et minnie driver
répète des mondes numéro 6 le monde ira
jusqu'à en oublier ses problèmes
les fans de la saga du lycée besoin que
ça soit réaliste cristal de ferhat tik
tok avec un dinosaure
je me sens pas très bien certains
d'entre vous sont positifs au virus it
électrique lorraine
je crois que lorraine n'est pas en forme
mais celui-là ne pose pas de souci
devrions-nous nous inquiéter de la
quantité de vomi déjà expulsé je sais
salut à tous ce qui se passe des trucs
très louche sur tournage de bêtes des
montagnes ont
[Musique]
découvert pourquoi tu ressembles à
bénédicte combats de chiens selon jo je
suis docteur stress ça fait flipper je
veux plus de benedict cumberbatch
nous retiennent contre notre gré
problème sur le plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce tournage devient réellement non porte
quoi
[Musique]
par peur de jouer avec des dinosaures
vraiment ce sont des faux je crois que
c'était un éléphant qui porte un masque
cours de l'histoire